for more on the derrick chauvin's
sentencing we're joined by cbs news
legal analyst ricky clement ricky good
morning
ricky good morning 22 and a half years
is
very specific when we're talking about
time here what can you tell us about the
judge's reasoning
the judge wrote a 22-page memorandum
to show that his reasoning is sound
there were four aggravating factors that
he found the prosecution had advocated
for
five but he only used two and rightly so
under the law in order to take the
sentence
up from the presumptive sentence of 12
and a half years
and bring it up to 22 and a half years
a 10-year enhancement those two factors
are abuse of trust and authority
on the part of derek shovin as well as
acting with particular cruelty
when you read through the memorandum
which is based on facts and law
what it comes down to is a grid of
sentencing guidelines
and when you look at aggravators these
two in particular
he looked at the average of cases and
the average of cases told him
that it was somewhere between 20 years
and
25 years was appropriate
he decided that he would split the
difference
and come up with 22 and a half years it
was a highly
appropriate sentence under the law ricky
we heard in jamie's report
chauvin obviously expected to appeal
what are some of the issues that
potential issues that we may see in that
let me count the ways as they say in
terms of potential issues there are a
myriad of them
we can begin with the issue of change of
venue
he wanted to change a venue from the
beginning in terms of prejudicial
pretrial publicity
secondly sequestration of the jury from
the moment the first
juror was chosen particularly after
there was a 27 million dollar settlement
that was announced we can go on into
maxine
water statement that was looked at by
the judge
and invited an issue of appeal
having to do with the fact of that
sanctity of the jury deliberation
process
and an invasion of that sanctity then
issues at trial
witnesses opining on excessive use of
force who weren't qualified
leading questions by the prosecutor
especially having to do with
feelings of witnesses when they were
fact witnesses which should be what you
saw
heard touched felt ricky very very
quickly before we go where will
derek children be held in prison
isolation or no
isolation for sure and jeffrey member
not only the
appeal there is another trial for
chauvin federally with the other
officers
the other officers also have a state
trial and i'd be
running to the courthouse if i were one
of those three
to get a plea deal okay ricky thank you
very much